great to see so many job fairs and
opportunities around
the city but this one this one will have
you soaring i am so excited about this
rocky is live at the fremont street
experience
to explain hey rocky
hey you guys yeah this one will have you
sorry in this wind
we'll have a soaring i'm trying not to
go over the barrier so we'll be zip
lining without all the proper
instructions here but i'm here with
andrew he is the ceo of the fremont
street experience so thank you for
everything you've brought to las vegas
oh well thank you for coming here today
on this beautiful windy day we have over
here on fremont street experience
i know so the so what we're talking
about today is apply
and fly kind of a metaphor for life but
also
just a really great opportunity to get a
job a really cool job
yeah this is the world's first rocky i
gotta tell you there's been nothing like
this in the world
you can go to our website
vegasexperience.com apply for a job to
be a ride operator here at slot zilla on
fremont street experience
you're going to come here 12 to 2 p.m if
invited on thursday
we're going to interview you right here
at the launch deck
you're going to fly the zip line for
free at 60 value
on the other side we're gonna let you
know if you have a job just like that
five minutes later you'll know if you
have a job
world's first flying interviews that is
so cool now just explain
what slot zola is for anybody out there
who doesn't know
sure we are on a 12 story high
zip line here at fremont street
experience that goes 750 feet
uh across the canopy here on fremont
five city blocks long
and again like i said the worst thing
that could happen is you're getting a
free 60
ride here at fremont street the best
thing you get a job with an up to
two thousand dollar bonus we help pay
for college expenses 401k healthcare
plans
so we're real excited to do a world's
first flying interview that is
incredible and it's such a great job
with really great benefits as well
what is it like from the ride operators
that you know to work up here
it's you know you're bringing joy to
people people come here to have fun in
las vegas and take a look at this i mean
you're going to fly down
the zip line and you're strapping people
in you're responsible for safety
responsible for fun and experience of a
lifetime people are also now they have
gopros so they're videotaping their
experiences down the zipline
we've had interesting videos going on
here different tv shows that have taped
here recently
so we're really excited by las vegas i
know you know so a lot of cool stuff
goes on here
but if you're a ride operator you're
having a lot of fun here every day
because we have a great team over here
on fremont street experience that's
awesome andrew last question
who is your ideal candidate out there
watching who are you speaking to right
now you know what we just want people
want to have fun and come down here in
fremont that are responsible enough to
strap people in here at the zip line
be a good team member who also you know
might have an interest in getting
college
tuition reimbursement but also want to
make money with a 2
000 bonus plan for a year and really
just good people we just want to have a
good time here at fremont street well
anything that's run by you i know it's
run by great people
i have to thank you on air he brought me
a hat
when he got here you guys so he already
knows me so well i love a hat i love a
great hat so this is awesome
well thank you for this this is my first
time here too oh wow this is your first
time
almost zillow yes we might have to put
you on the ride a little bit later
i don't know we'll have to see how it
goes free rides for rocky as well later
today
help me guys we'll see you in the four
o'clock put her
on yes put her on i want to see her fly
thanks rocky we'll check in with you
in the four o'clock news